how does it feel Freddie to be the
youngest person in the world with a
bionic arm awesome - tell me a bit more
about your arm what can you do with it
that you couldn't do before good how
about picking up what have you got in
your hand there you enjoying a sandwich
aren't your maybe it's a hamburger can
you pick that up for us I've got my
burger right now Wow look at that it
looks amazing so you come out you can
pick up food but you can play with your
skateboard you can play with your
scooters as that what is that what you
could do these days no I'm a I know I
cannot ride my scooter cause it's quake
world too fast and plus I can't raise
something with only two wheels yeah he's
only had the hand for a little while so
he's still still coming to turn you know
getting to grips with it so yeah I mean
there is a an awful lot more that he can
do with it and what's the habit of you
so quick leap you never learned mastered
it yeah it looks like magic how does it
work talkers how does it work
it's got like three of sensors on each
side of it to sense the muscle inside of
my hand there makes the fingers move Wow
we are very impressed here on Sky News
watching that Suzy let's bring you in of
course mum - Freddie he's doing amazing
well by the way we're sorry to interrupt
his afternoon snack and just tell us why
Freddie needed I mean he's he's he's
managed to arm all his life pretty well
I mean he's you know been very resilient
but I think in the last couple of years
really he's just felt more
self-conscious of it and the fact that
you know perhaps he can't do the same
things as other people and he's starting
to get that bit more frustrated about
possibly not being able to do certain
things so we were looking for quite a
long time really for you know some sort
of device that was not available on the
NHS that we could you know perhaps you
know get for him and then I
the advert for this open bannocks hero
arm and i thought that's just amazing
that's perfect for him so you know he's
just got a you know learn a bit more of
how it used how it uses it and it's
obviously using muscles that it doesn't
hasn't normally used because obviously
he doesn't have the hand so he's just
building up the strength in the arms
here to enable him to do more things
with it and it looks like he copes with
it really well it's all water off a
duck's back for him yeah yeah I mean he
put soon as it came out of the box he
put it on and he was using it
straightaway so yeah I think he's he's
getting to grips very very well Freddie
do you feel like a superhero I know it
feels real sweaty and sticky you can't
please a trolls camera doesn't matter
what you do but Freddie would eat what
do you make me go to school what do you
make think do you think it's awesome
yeah he's had quite a lot of attention
from from his friends at school with it
they're all quite very interested in it
wanted to try it on no they keep one in
there trying high-five me shake my hand
oh well that sounds cool so who is your
favorite superhero Oh who's your
favorite do you care about the Friday -
well he's sort of really into five
nights of Freddie at the moment event if
you have ever heard of that yeah no me
neither that's the thing of the movie
night well Freddie you know what the
best of luck we think you are awesome as
you think your arm is and what some
other thing you're hoping to do now with
it pop and meet that nice big hamburger
Susie what do you what do you hope to do
well I mean I want him to have get the
confidence to actually you know learn to
ride his bike properly without the
stabilizers this is a thing that's going
to give him the balance and stability